what do you think about the term toxic
masculinity
I think it's a toxic term
it escaped from the the margins of
Academia in about in 2016 not not
coincidentally
um and just became a term that was used
to apply essentially to any Behavior by
boys and men that the user disapproved
of uh it's rarely defined uh without any
specificity at all and so it's a in a
sense it's a completely vacuous term but
it's worse than that because by putting
those two words right next to each other
it actually repels a lot of boys and men
from a conversation about what it means
to be a man what it what it means to be
particularly mature I think to talk
about mature masculinity and immature
masculinity is quite useful but the idea
of toxic it's like Puritan it's like
it's ideal it reminds me the idea of
original sin in Christian theologies
right and and you need these exorcisms
you need someone to come and exercise if
you just weren't so male you'd be okay
and having raised three boys to
adulthood I gotta tell you that idea is
something toxic in them has to be
expunged is not a helpful way to raise
them so uh if we could if we could just
consign that particular term back to the
obscurity of academic journals that
would be great where did it come from
it was originally uh from uh from work
that was being done within cast very
violent incarcerated prisoners uh and so
there are a couple of academics that
were using it to talk about ways in
which you know very violent man who was
serving long prison sentences how their
views of masculinity had become
intertwined with ideas of expressed
violence and dominance and so on too and
and so it was a it was a concept that
was being used by a few psychologists
but but I think it had sort of it was
mentioned five times a year in academic
journals until 2016 and then overnight
it was on the front page of every
newspaper and so it it skept so you know
I think it did have some value in the
sense that there may be a a group very
small group of men for whom actually
their sense of what it means to be male
has in some ways become toxic but it was
always this tiny minority of men for
whom it was ever useful to apply it and
then suddenly Donald Trump got elected
need to
Etc and you know there you go I've heard
you say that it's a actual term to use
when one finds the behavior of any man
offensive or unpleasant and that's so
correct it's gone from being something
that's an aberration a complete outlier
to anything which is just slightly
objectionable
yeah that's the problem with it is that
there are many problems with it but like
any of these terms if it just expands
and expands and expands so everything
you know I think I I I just did a quick
search around and discovered that
everything from climate change to covid
to war to is the result of toxic
masculinity and you know if there was
resistance to getting vaccinated it was
toxic masculinity if you make a pass
it's toxic masculinity and and it was
just like being and actually there was
this I talk about this in my book there
was an incident that my kids High School
uh that got International attention as
an expression of toxic masculinity which
really woke me up to the way this term
has been sort of thrown around and used
indiscriminately
um but as I say it's not just it's not
just vacuous it's actively harmful and
interesting a lot of feminists will say
that now too there's a lot of people at
Helen Lewis who writes the Atlantic and
so on they're just saying look this term
is not helping us it's actually pushing
men away from a conversation about
masculinity and can we please stop using
it and so this is not a you know a right
wing View at all it's actually one that
a lot of feminists are just looking at
the data and saying if the goal here is
to have a good conversation with boys
and men about what it means to boys and
men this is not the way in it's a
terrible frame for that conversation
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]